madame la ministre dans un peu plus d'un
mois commencera la 22e Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar
sans préjugés de la sélection finale
cette année nous avons une équipe de
très haut niveau et cette coupe du monde
aurait dû être une très belle fête pour
la France pourtant on le voit il y a un
malaise qui monte pour ne pas dire du
dégoût y compris chez certains des plus
fervents supporters des Bleus en réalité
nous sommes face à un dilemme une
troisième étoile sur le maillot bleu
vaut-elle toutes les compromissions car
des compromissions il y en a eu et il y
en a encore en 2010 Kylian Mbappe
n'avait que 12 ans mais à cette époque
là Nicolas Sarkozy œuvrait déjà avec
succès pour que la monarchie cathari se
voit attribuer l'organisation de
l'événement 12 ans plus tard on
s'apprête à jouer la plus grande
compétition de football sur les cadavres
de 6500 travailleurs qui ont participé à
la construction des stades climatisés 12
ans plus tard les droits humains n'ont
pas progressé au Qatar les minorités
sexuelles sont toujours persécutés les
femmes ne sont pas libres l'esclavage
continue
12 ans plus tard le climat prend la
trajectoire du Kaos global et on
continue d'organiser des grands
événements sportifs dans le déni
climatique en dépit de toutes les
alertes de toutes les catastrophes de
tous les emballements et de tous les
drames qui surviennent alors vous me
direz madame la ministre vous n'êtes pas
comptable des compromission passées mais
la France s'apprête à exporter dès
demain son savoir-faire en matière de
sécurité en le mettant au service de la
dictature cathari avec l'envoi de 220
gendarmes mais agent de sécurité civile
tous des hommes bien sûr pour ne choquer
pour ne pas choquer le rigorisme
religieux des émirs pourtant madame la
ministre au-delà du rayonnement de nos
équipes nationales le sport français
devrait être un réel vecteur
d'engagement en faveur des droits
humains et du climat ma question est
donc la même que celle que je posais à
votre prédécesseur il y a quelques mois
à l'occasion des JO au pays du génocide
ouigourd si nos joueurs n'ont pas assumé
les choix politiques de la France
allez-vous de votre côté au moins
boycotter diplomatiquement cette Coupe
du Monde de la honte et de la
compromission et allez-vous enfin
engager votre ministère dans une réelle
diplomatie sportive au service du climat
et des droits humains
pour vous répondre la parole de Cabana
le ministre des Sports et des Jeux
Olympiques paralympiques madame houndéa
j'avais la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
dessus un rappel en effet liminaire si
vous me le permettez la décision prise
par la FIFA d'attribuer la Coupe du
Monde 2022 au Qatar a été prise il y a
12 ans
dans un tout autre contexte notre
urgence écologique elle est bien entendu
plus prégnante que jamais nous
souhaitons que le
Qatar face tout ce qu'il doit pour tenir
l'objectif de neutralité carbone qu'il a
affiché pour le Mondial
il a indiqué le pays pouvoir s'appuyer
pour cela sur un système de transport en
commun ambitieux d'ailleurs bâti pour
l'occasion avec l'expertise française et
des investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables de tout premier plan
au-delà de ça dans ce chemin vers le
Mondial nous voulons évidemment
encourager le Qatar à poursuivre son
engagement pour mettre pleinement en
œuvre l'accord de Paris est réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
sommes d'ailleurs engagés dans des
coopérations techniques pour accélérer
les efforts de ce pays dans ce sens en
prévision de la COP 27 de charmelcher
nous espérons que le Qatar pourra
soumettre une contribution nationale
réhausser et une stratégie de long terme
davantage alignée sur l'objectif de
limitation de l'objectif de
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degrés
s'agissant des droits humains je crois
que le combat de notre pays en
bilatérale en multilatérales dans
l'enceinte de loïcité et avec les ONG
dans human right Swatch dont Amnesty
internationale porte très haut ce combat
il a marqué de premier progrès en 2018
et en 2020 à travers une législation qui
évolue mais c'est progrès sont tout à
fait insuffisants et nous veillons à
chacune des interactions à ce pays à
promouvoir le respect de l'ensemble des
droits humains mais vous avez raison
derrière votre question c'est bien le
modèle futur que nous voulons pour nos
grands événements sportifs
internationaux et les critères qui
président à leur choix à leur
localisation au cahier des charges de
ces événements deux premiers espoirs
nous entendons la FIFA qui appelle de
ses vœux se renforcement commentaires
environnementaux dans les appels
d'offres pour les enfants
pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques des jeux les plus
écologiques de l'histoire nous tiendrons
cet engagement de la même façon que dans
la foulée du plan de sobriété
énergétique portée par la terminer
[Musique]